(upbeat music)
- Hi!
Hi guys!
Yes, yes!
And with that flower power,
I say to thee, guess what?
I fixed a toilet last night.
(audience cheers)
Yes!
I did.
Yeah, that's my Bruce Lee bada-bing.
Listen, I felt like a man last night!
I did, because you know what?
Most of the time when
stuff like that happens,
I'm like, oh, help me, oh God.
But last night I was like, you know what?
Just lifted the lid off,
rolled up the sleeves,
went in, yanked the chain, reattached it.
And it worked!
(audience cheers)
I know it's so silly, but...
You know, listen, we've all had to learn
how to take care of
ourselves in a different way,
because we're all stuck in our houses
and no one's around to help.
So we gotta figure this out.
And I wanna ask my BFFs,
has anyone else here
had a domestic Everest that they climbed?
#DomesticEverest.
Carly.
- Hi.
- Hi Drew.
- Hi ladies!
How are you?
- Oh we're so excited.
- So excited.
- Oh, you both look like
you're going to prom.
I mean, I'm not kidding.
- Wow.
- Thank you.
- Gorgeous.
Did you guys have a domestic
Everest you climbed?
- Yes, yes, we recently moved
from Southern California
to Northern California and
I was missing the L.A. area.
So I decided to remodel my master bedroom
to be more like an LA vibe.
I did it all by myself.
(audience claps)
- I mean, that really
is a domestic Everest.
Mine was more like a domestic
Denali, maybe a Fuji.
That is Everest, I am so impressed.
Good for you, and thank you
for inspiring us to just
get it done, you know?
Thank you ladies, and you
could not look more beautiful.
Okay, I am so excited for the show.
We are talking to a woman
who's turned a cancer diagnosis
into a nationwide runners community.
And I'm actually gonna try
and attempt to join this community myself.
So I'm excited to present this
to all of you as an option.
And I'm also gonna step into the kitchen.
I'm doing a cooking demo for a dish
that is very, very important to me,
and satiates something that
is sort of a naughty dish,
but I found a way to make it a nice dish.
So first let's kick it
off with some Drew's News.
We like to serve our
stories here sunny side up.
It's Drew's News.
(audience cheers)
(car crashes)
(cat hisses)
Ma'am, I asked you a question.
It's Drew's News!
(audience cheers)
I just really wanna thank our VFFs today,
because I felt so connected to everyone.
I mean really, this is like
an awesome crowd today,
and every day here is, with our VFFs.
I love hanging out with everyone.
All right, let's kick
it off with the news.
We try to find the good little morsels
that carry us throughout the day.
It's time for history, herstory!
Herstory football!
That's right, this Sunday
for the first time ever,
three women were on the field
at an official NFL game, okay?
Yeah, that happened.
(audience claps)
At the Washington/Cleveland game
there was one female coach for each team,
and one female referee
officiating the game,
Callie Brownson, Jennifer
King and Sarah Thomas.
(audience cheers)
I love this story.
This herstory!
Thank you ladies, making us all look good.
Okay, next up in the news,
it's a story that your stomach cares about
because it's food news.
- [Woman] Nom, nom, nom, nom.
- (laughs) Delish.com reports that Nabisco
has released their limited
edition Maple Cream Oreo.
And it's two golden cookies
with maple syrup flavor,
stuffed with the traditional Oreo cream
we all know and love.
I mean, if it didn't have
that, it wouldn't be an Oreo.
So I wanna try this.
I met a really fun friend
in the VFF Wall, Jason,
and I asked him to come
back here, actually.
We did a turkey dinner
candy corn taste test
last week, and I loved his review.
So I'm bringing him back.
Jason, how are ya?
- Hi Drew, hello, I'm great.
- Hi.
- Thank you for having me.
- I just was like, we
all love you so much.
We were like, will Jason come back?
So thank you.
- I did.
- You came back, Jason,
how do you rock an Oreo?
- You know, I just, old-school fashion.
Just a little milk.
You know, I let it sit in
there for a little bit,
then I take it out and eat it.
But yeah, a little milk.
I don't have milk for today.
- I was just gonna say,
now I'm so disappointed.
I should've...
Next time we will have
a cold milk standing by.
Okay, so shall we taste test these?
You ready?
- Let's do it, here we go.
- Cheers.
(audience laughs)
- Me likey.
- That's fall.
- Yeah.
- That's fall in a cookie.
- It's also like IHOP in your mouth.
- Yeah.
- It's like maple syrup,
Vermont party right here.
- Yeah, like I can't go to Canada anymore,
because they won't let us in.
So I'm just gonna eat these instead.
- Yeah, you got your
maple leaf right here.
- Oh, that's perfect.
- Oh my god, these are
really good, I'm not kidding.
They have almost like that maple smoke,
it's beautiful, wow.
All right, we have to move on.
Okay, that's really hard to put down.
All right, Jason, do you have the samosas?
- I have them right here.
And this has been very
difficult all morning
because they have smelled so good.
- They're kind of one of my
favorite treats in the world.
Fun fact, they are a
savory Indian puff pastry
filled with potatoes and vegetables.
And it's one of my favorite things to eat.
And this one has a pumpkin spiced samosa.
Trader Joe's just released this pairing
that made me go, oh my gourd.
Here we go, ready?
- Let's do it.
- Oh my god, oh my god.
- I didn't expect that,
did not expect that.
- That is so good.
- That is delicious, spicy too.
- And the pumpkin really worked
'cause you already are
used to like a potato vibe.
- Yeah.
- By the way, Trader Joe's food reviews
on Instagram, are you on that, Jason?
Anyone?
It's the best, it's
really good, get on it.
- I will get on it today.
- Oh my god, this is so amazing.
- Thank you, Jason.
From VFF to FFF, favorite
foodie friend forever.
That might be four Fs.
(upbeat music)